hi there
day 86 except we're gonna actually the
last day is going to be
april the 15th which is next tuesday
so today being thursday friday saturday
sunday monday tuesday i have five days
um
i'm going to meet all my goals except
for writing which i kind of put off
as i've said almost intending not to do
so and then i was pressured to doing so
and i'm glad today i wrote
250 words which i submitted for
correction on our exchange at link
got the uh correction back right away
from one of our korean
native speaking members
um it was great to see the corrections
um it's really it's good you know it
helps me focus it helps me notice
when i'm writing and it takes me a while
to to write 250 words you know i almost
i have the feeling that i wish i were
reading and learning new words and and
doing the things that i most enjoy doing
but
you know i realize that this writing has
got me focusing better i'm more aware of
like some of these sounds in korean
you could use
several symbols for the o sound or for
the a sound and so you start to notice
which ones are used you start to notice
how the words are grouped together
bunched together
so and i think this improves my reading
and proves my comprehension
so the writing
i see the writing and even to some
extent speaking
more as a tool to help me notice so that
that i get more out of my listening and
reading
because to me and i know i was on some
exchange somewhere and somebody was
saying that or on someone's blog that
they were so happy because within two or
three weeks of learning chinese they
were able to put full sentences together
uh i have no interest in being able to
put full sentences together after two or
three weeks doesn't concern me at all
um
my task in learning a language the sort
of basic building blocks blocks to me
are are the words and the phrases i have
to get them in me
whether i can
put phrases together correctly
incorrectly initially uh you know often
in korean they'll teach you the
different polite forms
and you know the names of the different
relationships older brother younger
sister and i have no interest in that at
all to me that is all periphery that's
all kind of decoration the basic
building blocks that i want is is words
uh and lots of words and to get used to
them so that then i can listen to
interesting content like i'm listening
to right now and continue to enjoy the
language consume the language and let
the language grow in me and then at some
point i'll start putting full sentences
together now that i start writing i'm
putting full sentences together i'm
making mistakes spelling mistakes and
mistakes of structure but i am putting
full sentences together and talking
about rather complicated subjects now
that i start writing
so uh however so you know and given that
again i'm
i wouldn't say i'm a dilettante but i do
what i like to do so i mostly listen and
read and but being sort of nudged into
writing uh i wouldn't want to spend too
much time on it but it's it's true like
today i wrote 250 words i hope i don't
think i'll be able to but i'm going to
try to write 250 words for the next five
days i don't think i will but i might
write another thousand words so i've
written a total of about 670 so far so i
might get to say 1500 words which is
half of the goals uh the goal that i had
set for myself i now regret that i
didn't start earlier on the writing i
think it would have helped me it would
have taken time away from my reading and
listening but it would have helped me to
notice help me in other ways
so that you know i'm glad i'm doing it
uh
but as i say
the the main task for me in language
learning is the words because
later on you can always learn about the
names of
relationships or
or you know different levels of
formality
but to understand
you know
substance substantive content you need
words and you need a lot of exposure and
so as i often say i mean that's where i
spend most of my time but
because as i you know attitude got to be
motivated interested confident
time you got to spend the time and you
have to you know develop the ability to
notice and there's no question that
writing seeing the writing corrected
speaking as we do at least seeing the
speaking corrected when it comes back to
you as a report all of that helps you to
notice so that you actually derive more
benefit than when you do your listening
and reading
so
uh
just kind of to this i also had a
discussion today for half an hour with
clara uh in paris
and i'm gonna speak to her at least once
more possibly twice more and then
probably record it as as my sort of
final
uh video in this 90-day challenge but i
have my kim jong-un podcast i have
enough there to keep me going
uh i you know it's so rewarding now i
can read through his podcast and there's
not that many words now that you know a
lot of the yellow words now i've come to
know them and there's fewer and fewer
blue words
uh and many of the blue words are just
forms of words that i already know so as
i've said before i'm over the hump i'm
on my way and if i if i
basically go through all of kim
jung-ha's podcasts uh
you know i'll i'll fix up the the
decoration you know the the fine points
of the
politeness levels and all of that
at the end
i'm not too concerned about it now so
that's basically my report for today
and uh
we're almost at the end here not the end
of my korean studies but the end of the
90 day challenge